over the last 12 years iceland has
ranked number one in the list of
countries closing the equality gap
between men and women canadian-born
eliza reid is now the country's first
lady and in her book secrets of the
spaka she asks how and why iceland is
leading the way to global gender
equality and she's with us now eliza
thanks for joining us or should i say ms
reed forgive me thank you for joining us
on the programme this morning why in
your opinion is iceland the best place
to live if you're a woman there are a
lot of different reasons but to
summarize them in a nutshell i think we
have wonderful policies here that are
supportive for families especially that
encourage fathers to be involved from an
early age in their children's upbringing
and and make it simpler for women to
return to the workforce and really we've
passed the tipping point as a society
here uh in terms of the fact that we
realize that we're no longer debating
whether trying to achieve gender
equality is an important objective but
how we are going to get there and that
means that we see many more women in in
public life and role models we see the
public speaking out for
uh
for things that we see in the media when
there's misrepresentation issues like
that because we are seeing here and
realizing that of course working towards
achieving gender equality is something
that is going to benefit everyone in
society it's not a zero-sum game of one
group versus another group
you talk about gender equality in
iceland i'm quoting you from a deep
seated cultural sense of fairness what
do you mean by that
i mean i think maybe that's the the sort
of a nordic model there again
egalitarian the idea that we all have an
opportunity to contribute to society and
we all deserve to uh reap the benefits
of of our society and what we are doing
and i think gender equality is the
perfect example of that where again it's
a it's an objective that is going to
benefit everyone because we know that
societies that are more gender equal uh
are are more peaceful they are happier
they have longer living populations the
the companies and organizations do
better on their bottom line so it's it
doesn't have downsides
which women in history do you look up to
the most
goodness that's a difficult question in
iceland we have a wonderful role model
victims finn bogadolte who is the
world's first democratically elected
female head of state and she served as
president for 16 years here which of
course means that an entire generation
of women in iceland grew up with a
female head of state and i think public
figures like that are very important but
also personally i was very fortunate in
my own life in canada growing up to have
very strong female role models within my
own family who encouraged me of course
to do anything that i wanted to do with
my life
you could steal a couple of mine if
you'd like to diana princess of wales i
always thought she was an amazing woman
given the challenges that she was facing
in her life mother teresa and why not no
explanation necessary and madeleine
albright who sadly just died she you'll
remember that she had the quote there's
a special place in hell for women who
don't support other women and i often um
use that quote uh when i'm talking to uh
to younger women and men um as far as
iceland is a beautiful country i've been
um obviously to reykjavik and i've been
to the north of the country as well it's
a beautiful beautiful country and you
are doing your bits aren't you as far as
ukrainian refugees are concerned do you
feel you're doing enough
i think we can always be doing more and
i think that that's something that
people in the population feel of course
here that everybody uh is is devastated
and and horrified by what is happening
we're trying to do our best uh we our
doors are open we have had hundreds of
refugees who are coming in and and maybe
hundreds sounds small but our population
is quite small as well and we're a
little farther away um we are doing our
best to to uh yes uh have people over in
refugees and and sending money and uh
logistical assistance and investing more
in um
in
cyber security iceland actually has no
military of course but we are a nato
nation and are committed of course to to
doing our part as a nato country uh to
help in this war
uh the world economic forum's global
gender gap report ranks iceland first
for closing the gender gap good for you
guys uh the united kingdom is 23rd
what more can we do
goodness well there's a lot more and i
my my book absolutely is not designed to
tell other countries what they should be
doing but hopefully to inspire people on
an individual basis um as far as
as as countries and policies are
concerned absolutely our policy of
affordable child care and excellent
parental leave for both parents has been
very helpful but what i'm hoping to be
able to do with my book and the stories
of the the sprachar which means
outstanding women in icelandic uh the
stories of these outstanding women i
hope will inspire all of us on an
individual basis to use our voices and
to be positive role models and to
encourage other people to use their
voices and have a diverse range of
experiences that we're sharing and also
for men to be encouraged and involved to
know that that the gender equality fight
isn't a women's issue fight it's
something for everybody that is going to
benefit all of us how does a foreigner
become first lady
mary the president is the short answer
but
um
the the the dollar answers that my
husband who is now the president and i
met uh at oxford actually in graduate
school and uh and he's a historian by
training and uh there's a bit of a story
in the book there we we met on a on a
blind date that i contrived i suppose
you could say and uh and then we we
moved here
to to build a life here in iceland and
raise our family here oh that's amazing
what a great story thank you for joining
us look forward to reading the book in
more detail thank you thank you thanks a
lot